mehr als zwei millionen menschen sind
nach polen gekommen in nur drei wochen
das sind zehnmal so viele flüchtlinge
wie in deutschland
ein land öffnet türen und herzen für
menschen in not und die ringen um worte
wir sind so dankbar für die hilfe hier
aber wir wollen nach hause
die ukraine muss den krieg gewinnen
damit wir nach hause können
warschau hauptbahnhof an keinem ort in
europa stranden so viele ukraine die
hier
thomas und marta haben wie fast alle
ihrer freunde flüchtlinge aufgenommen
seit jahren wird ihr land in europa für
seine abwehrhaltung kritisiert jetzt
seit putins krieg die polen in neuem
licht
ich war anfangs überrascht aber jetzt
macht es mich stolz dass die leute hier
so reagieren wie sie reagieren dieser
krieg berührt uns alle ganz tief weil
das unsere nachbarn sind
2015 haben sich die polen vehement gegen
die aufnahme von syrern gestemmt ihre
blockade von damals spaltet europa bis
heute
jetzt sind die ukraine bekommen und das
land preist sich für sein gutes
management wie hier bei der
registrierung im nationalstadion
und doch hat die regierung nicht nur ihr
image im sinn sondern auch ihre
jahrelangen kämpfe mit der eu es gibt
eine fraktion in der regierung die das
genauso benutzt wie sie sind die wissen
wie sie in den letzten monaten und
jahren argumentiert hat der hat die sagt
nämlich es gibt wichtig seien wichtiger
was als rechtsstaatlichkeit jetzt also
her mit dem geld wir sind helfen wir
neben flüchtlinge auf uns darf man nicht
sanktionieren
ohne all die freiwilligen helfer stünden
land und regierung allerdings längst vor
dem kollaps und polen beginnt schon mit
der integration
75.000 ukrainische kinder wurden bereits
eingeschult auch heute begrüßt warschaus
oberbürgermeisters kowski wieder neue
schüler er gehört nicht zur
nationalistischen regierungspartei ps
sondern ist liberal und fordert anders
als die regierung eine europäische
lösung
das würde den vergangenen gut zwei
wochen sind allein in warschau 300.000
menschen angekommen wenn wir uns an 2015
erinnern damals waren es 200.000 in ganz
europa in einem monat wir tun unser
bestes aber wir können nicht länger
improvisieren deshalb brauchen wir ein
verteilungsmechanismus in europa
berlin hauptbahnhof im vergleich zu
polen kommt hier nur ein bruchteil der
menschen an doch auch ohne europäische
verteilung geraten sie hier gefährlich
nah ans limit
2015 ist die stadt an der letzten großen
flüchtlingswelle gescheitert jetzt soll
alles besser klappen irgendwie
verspricht die bürgermeisterin
ist ein großer unterschied zur situation
2015 und heute wir haben gute
voraussetzungen um es diesmal besser zu
machen und wir haben lessons learned die
wir jetzt auch anwenden können auf allen
ebenen diese bilder boten frontal
zugespielt sie zeigen die
flüchtlingsunterkunft in der berliner
messe ende der vergangenen woche
feldbetten dicht an dicht sonst nicht
viel eine freiwillige helferin schildert
uns ihre eindrücke
sie möchte unerkannt bleiben
duschen sind leider überhaupt nicht
vorhanden viele menschen fragen danach
einige sind seit zehn tagen oder länger
auf der flucht dementsprechend ist halt
auch der geruch in der hna und ich finde
das ist eine situation die ist für
menschen einfach nicht zumutbar
900 menschen sollen hier bleiben können
ohne duschen medikamente gebe es nur
vormittags polizei praktisch keine
helfer die das schildern fühlen sich von
der politik alleingelassen
wir sind wirklich maßlos übermüdet am
ende unserer kräfte wir hatten auch
schon helfer die wirklich
zusammengebrochen sind und nach hause
geschickt werden mussten oder gar nicht
mehr kommen können da wäre es ja auch
irgendwie schön wenn man mehr
unterstützung von der politik erfahren
würde
lessons learned lektion gelernt frontal
hätte darüber gerne mit der
bürgermeisterin gesprochen doch unsere
anfrage blieb unbeantwortet
es verwundert sich in der tat dass
bund und auch die länder sozusagen nicht
gelernt haben insofern auch wieder die
zivilgesellschaft ist viel viel weiter
als sozusagen der staat das war 2015 ja
auch schon auch damals hieß es wir
schaffen das und man hat es letztendlich
die krise nur bewältigt in dem
wahnsinnig viele menschen
engagierte münchen hauptbahnhof auch
hier steigt die zahl der ankömmlinge aus
der ukraine stetig
2015 stand der bahnhof für ein phänomen
das weltweit von sich reden machte die
deutsche willkommenskultur
heute stehen manche geflüchtete die
ganze nacht in der schlange um an geld
zu kommen und das nötigste
wir haben überhaupt kein geld und das
geht in unserer unterkunft vielen so
unser ukrainisches geld ist hier wie
zeitungspapier wir können es nicht
umtauschen
anders als 2015 müssen ukraine zwar kein
asyl beantragen doch weil sie deshalb
auch nicht registriert werden ist die
verteilung schwierig später und
reflexartige hilfe rufe die ägyptische
flüchtlinge ist eine enorm große aufgabe
ja es ist eine nationale aufgabe das
geht nur in einer gesamt verteilung eben
engagement der bundesländer aber auch
engagement des bundes etliche
bundesländer sind nicht in der lage das
finanziell zu schultern
bei der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz am
vergangenen donnerstag beschließen bund
und länder keine lastenteilung sondern
eine arbeitsgruppe die soll bis siebte
april vor allem die kostenfrage klären
nachfrage beim regierungssprecher nach
drei kriegswochen hat die
bundesregierung eine arbeitsgruppe
gegründet ist das angemessen sie sagen
drei wochen ist viel ich finde nach drei
wochen läuft es ganz gut und trotzdem
muss uns auch klar sein das ist jetzt
erst der anfang
2015 da hatten wir diese diskussion alle
schon mal hätte man da nicht jetzt
schneller in gang kommen müssen ich
glaube die situation sind nicht ganz
vergleichbar davon abgesehen teile ich
die prämisse die sie jetzt das dritte
mal formulieren nicht und weisen sie ein
drittes mal zurück dass man zu langsam
sei auch nicht in die gänge gekommen
sein seit fast vier wochen tobt der
krieg in der ukraine mit bis zu zehn
millionen menschen ist das schon jetzt
die größte flucht bewegung seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg
die deutsche politik reagiert seltsam
träger auf kosten von freiwilligen und
flüchtenden